[Music]
as this narrative is in my opinion of no
trivial value to those who in your name
go to subdue those countries and bring
them to a knowledge of the true faith
and true lord and under the imperial
dominion i have written this with much
exactness and although in it maybe read
things very novel and for some persons
difficult to believe nevertheless they
may without hesitation credit me as
strictly faithful
better than to exaggerate i have
lessened in all things
and it is sufficient to say the relation
is offered to your majesty
in truth
on the 17th day of june in the year 1527
the governor left the port of san luca
de barameda authorised and commanded by
your majesty to conquer and govern the
provinces of the maine extending from
the river palmas to the cape of florida
the fleet he took was five ships in
which went 600 men a few more or less
the officers were these with their rank
myself quebec the backer treasurer and
high sheriff alfonso enrique comptroller
alonso de solis distributed to your
majesty and assessor juan suarez a friar
of saint francis commissary and four
more friars of the same order
a wind came from the south which drove
us from the land towards the coast of
florida we came inside on tuesday the
12th day of april and sailed along the
coast on holy thursday we anchored near
the shore in the mouth of a bay at the
head of which we saw some houses or
habitations of indians the next day the
governor raised ensigns for your majesty
and took possession of the country in
your royal name the following day the
indians of the town came and spoke to us
but as we had no interpreter we could
not understand what was meant they made
many signs and menaces and appeared to
say that we must go away from the
country with this they left us and went
off offering no interruption
the governor called us aside being
together he said that he desired to
penetrate the interior
he asked us for our views
i said it appeared to me that under no
circumstances are we to leave the
vessels until they were in a secure and
peopled harbour the horses were in no
condition to service in such
circumstances this might occur above all
that we were going without being able to
communicate with the indians by use of
speech and without an interpreter and we
could but poorly understand ourselves
with them or learn what we desired to
know of the land that we were about to
enter a country of which we had no
account and had no knowledge of its
character of what there was in it or by
what people inhabited and besides all
this we had not food to sustain us in
wandering we knew not wither
but
to the commissary everything appeared
otherwise
and on saturday first of may the date of
this occurrence the governor ordered to
each man going with him two pounds of
biscuit and half a pound of bacon
and thus ritual we took up our march
into the country
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question what was the first country to
recognize the united states as a nation
a the united kingdom
b morocco or c france
yes that's right it was technically
france even though morocco did send the
first letter granting access to
morocco's ports in 1777.
thanks wikipedia and a great place to go
if your knowledge of american history is
a little rusty like me is our
documentary recommendation this month
spirit of the pony express a heartfelt
tribute to the legendary but short-lived
postal service full of historical sites
across america and eccentric characters
it's a cracking watch and magellan have
more than 3 000 other documentaries on a
wide range of topics to check out too so
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers
thanks
we of the mounted men consisted of 40.
we traveled on the allowance we had
received 15 days without finding any
other thing to eat than palmitos which
are like those of andalucia in all that
time we saw not an indian and found
neither village nor house
we were going ever in quest of apalachee
the country of which the indians told us
having for our guides those we had taken
while going on our way a number came in
sight prepared for battle and though we
called to them they would not return nor
await our arrival but retired following
us on the road the governor left some
cavalry in ambush which sallying as the
natives are about to pass seized three
or four who thenceforth served as guides
that night we came to a wide and deep
river with a very rapid current
as we would not venture to cross on
rafts we made a canoe for the purpose
and spent a day in getting over had the
indians desired to oppose us they could
well have disputed our passage for even
with their help we had great difficulty
in making it one of the mounted men juan
velasquez by name a native of cuellar
impatient of detention entered the river
when the violence of the current casting
him from his horse he grasped the reins
of the bridal and both were drowned
the people of that chief
found the body of the beast and having
told us about where in the stream below
we could find the corpse it was sought
for
this death caused us much regret for
until now not a man had been lost
the horse afforded supper to many that
night
they conducted us through a country very
difficult to travel and wonderful to
look upon innate of vast forests the
trees being astonishingly high so many
were fallen on the ground as to obstruct
our way in such a manner that we could
not advance without much going about and
a considerable increase of toil
many of the standing trees were riven
from top to bottom by bolts of lightning
which fall in that country of frequent
storms and tempests
[Music]
the indians we had seen so far in
florida are all archers they go naked a
large of body and appear at a distance
like giants they are of admirable
proportions very spare and of great
activity and strength the bows they use
are as thick as the arm of 11 or 12
palms in length which they will
discharge at 200 paces with so great a
precision that they miss nothing
the journey onwards was extremely
arduous there were not horses enough to
carry the sick who went on increasing in
numbers day by day and we knew of no
cure
it was piteous and painful to witness
our perplexity and distress i cease here
to relate more of this
because anyone may suppose what would
occur in a country so remote and malign
the governor called all to him and of
each apart he asked advice as to what he
should do to get out of a country so
miserable this with many other
embarrassments being considered and
entertaining many plans we coincided in
one great project extremely difficult to
put into operation and that was to build
vessels in which we might get away this
appeared impossible to everyone we knew
not how to construct nor were there
tools nor iron finally no one thing of
so many that are necessary nor any man
who had any knowledge of their
manufacture and above all there was
nothing to eat
while building for those who should
labor before we embarked there died more
than 40 men of disease and hunger
without enumerating those destroyed by
the indians
by the 22nd of the month of september
the horses had been consumed only one
remaining and only on that day we
embarked
but a heavy storm came on that detained
us for six days we not daring to go to
the sea and as it was now five days
since we had drunk our thirst was so
excessive that it put us to the
extremity of swallowing salt water
by which some of the men became so
crazed that three or four
suddenly died
i state this so briefly because i do not
believe there is any necessity for
particularly relating the sufferings and
toils amongst which we found ourselves
since considering the place where we
were and the little hope we had of
relief
everyone may conceive much of what must
have passed
the cold was severe and our bodies were
so emaciated the bones might be counted
with little difficulty having become the
perfect figures of death for myself i
can say that from the month of may past
i had eaten no other thing than maize
and sometimes i found myself obliged to
eat it unparched for although the beasts
were slaughtered while the boats were
building i could never eat their flesh
and i did not eat fish ten times i state
this to avoid giving excuses and that
everyone may judge in what condition we
were
i talked with the christians and said
that if it appeared well to them i would
beg the indians to take us to their
houses some who had been in new spain
replied that we ought not to think of it
for if they should do so they would
sacrifice us to their idols
but seeing no better course and that any
other led to a nearer and more certain
death i disregarded what was said and
besought the indians to take us to their
dwellings
they signified that it would give them
delight and that we should tarry a
little that they might do what we asked
presently thirty men loaded themselves
with wood and started for their houses
an hour after our arrival they began to
dance and hold great rejoicing which
lasted all night
although for us there was no joy
festivity nor sleep awaiting the hour
they should make us victims
but
in the morning they gave us fish and
roots
showing us such hospitality that we were
reassured and lost somewhat the fear of
sacrifice
[Music]
to this island we gave the name malhado
the people we found there are large and
well-formed they have no other arms than
bows and arrows the men have one of
their nipples bored from side to side
and some have both wearing a cane in
each they have the underlip also board
and wearing it a piece of cane the
breadth of half a finger their women are
accustomed to great toil the stay they
make on the island is from october to
the end of february
these people love their offspring more
than any in the world and treat them
with the greatest mildness
when it occurs that the sun dies the
parents and kindred weep as does
everybody the wailing continuing for a
whole year after a year of mourning has
passed to the rights of the dead are
performed then they wash and purify
themselves from the stain of smoke
though the meant all their deceased in
this manner except the aged for whom
they show no regret as they say that
their season has passed they having no
enjoyment and their living they would
occupy the earth and take ailment from
the young
every man has an acknowledged wife the
physicians are allowed more freedom they
may have two or three wives among whom
exist the greatest friendship and
harmony
on an island of which i have spoken they
wish to make us physicians without
examination or inquiring for diplomas
they cure by blowing upon the sick and
with that breath and the imposing of
hands they cast out infirmity their
custom is on finding themselves sick to
send for a physician and after he has
applied the cure they give him not only
all they have but seek among their
relatives for more to give
our method was to bless the sick
breathing upon them and reciting a
paternoster and an ave maria praying
with all earnestness to god our lord
that he would give health and influence
them to make us some good return
in his clemency he willed that all those
for whom we supplicated should tell the
others that they were sound and in
health directly after we made the sign
of the blessed cross over them for this
the indians treated us kindly they
deprived themselves of food that they
might give to us and presented us with
skins and some trifles
so protracted was the hunger we there
experienced that many times i was three
days without eating the natives also
endured as much and it appeared to me a
thing impossible that life could be so
prolonged although afterwards i found
myself in greater hunger and necessity
which i shall speak of further on i was
obliged to remain with the people
belonging to this island more than a
year and because of the hard work they
put upon me and the harsh treatment i
resolved to flee from them and go to
those of chiruko who inhabit the forests
and country of the main the life i laid
being unbearable
besides much other labor i had to get
out roots from below the water and from
among the cane where they grew in the
ground from this employment i had my
fingers so worn that did a straw but
touch them they would bleed accordingly
i put myself to contriving how i might
go over to the other indians among whom
matters turned somewhat more favorably
for me
i set to trafficking and strove to make
my employment profitable in the ways i
could best contrive and by that means i
got food and good treatment
the indians would beg me to go from one
quarter to another for things of which
they have need for in consequence of
incessant hostilities they could not
traverse the country nor make many
exchanges with my merchandise and trade
i went into the interior as far as i
pleased and travelled along the coast 40
or 50 leagues the principal wares were
cones and other pieces of sea snail
conches used for cutting and fruit like
a bean of the highest value among them
which they use as a medicine and employ
in their dances and festivities
such were what i carried into the
interior and in bata i got and brought
back skins ochre with which they rub and
colour the face hard canes of which to
make arrows and tassels of the hair of
deer that by dying they make red this
occupation suited me well for the travel
allowed me liberty to go where i wished
i was not obliged to work and was not a
slave my leading object while journeying
in this business was to find out the way
by which i should go forward and i
became well known the inhabitants were
pleased when they saw me and those who
did not know me sought and desired the
acquaintance for my reputation the
hardships that i underwent in this were
long to tell as well as peril and
privation as of storms and cold
often times they overtook me alone and
in the wilderness but i came forth from
them all by the great mercy of god our
lord
i was in this country nearly six years
alone among the indians and naked
like them
i moved on and remained with the
avavares people eight months reckoned by
the number of moons in all this time
people came to see us from many parts
and they said that most truly we were
children of the sun because of the great
solicitation made by these coming from
different parts to find us
we all became physicians although in
being venturous and bold to attempt the
performance of any cure i was the most
remarkable no one whom we treated but
told us that he left well and so great
was the confidence that they would
become healed if we administered to them
they even believed that whilst we
remained none of them could die
these and the rest of the people behind
related an extraordinary circumstance
and by the way they counted there
appeared to be 15 or 16 years since it
occurred
they said that a man wandered through
the country whom they called bad thing
he was small of body and wore a beard
and they never distinctly saw his
features
when he came to the house where they
lived their hair stood up and trembled
when he entered and seized whom he chose
and giving them three great gashes in
the side with a very sharp flint he put
his hand through them drawing forth the
entrails from one of which he would cut
off a portion more or less the length of
a palm and throw it on the embers
a little after this he would begin to
unite it and putting his hands on the
wounds these would instantly become
healed
these things they told us of we much
laughed at and ridiculed and they seeing
our incredulity brought to us many of
those they said he had seized
we told them he was an evil one and in
the best way we could gave them to
understand that if they would believe in
god our lord and become christians like
us they need have no fear of him nor
would he dare to come and inflict these
injuries and they might be certain he
would not venture to appear while we
remained in the land
they were all ignorant of time either by
the sun or moon nor do they reckon by
the month or year they better know and
understand the differences of the
seasons when the fruits come to ripen
where the fish resort and the position
of the stars which they are ready and
practiced
we always went naked like them and
covered ourselves at night with
deerskins
the children are suckled until the age
of 12 years when they are old enough to
get support for themselves
we asked why they rear them in this
manner and they said because of the
great poverty of the land
they are all war-like and have as much
strategy for protecting themselves
against enemies as they could have where
they reared in italy in continual feuds
they are the most watchful in danger of
any people i know if they fear an enemy
they are awake all night long even with
a bow at his side and a dozen arrows
they all differ in their habitations
towns and tongues everywhere they
produce stupefaction with a smoke
and for that they will give whatever
they possess
when the women have their indisposition
they seek food only for themselves as no
one else will eat of what they bring
in the time i was among these people i
witnessed a diabolical practice
a man living with another one of those
who are emasculate and impotent
these go habited like women and perform
their duties use the bow and carry heavy
loads among them we saw many mutilated
in the way i describe
they are more muscular than the other
men and taller
they bear very weighty burdens
when we saw sure signs of christians and
heard how near we were to them we gave
thanks to lord our god for having chosen
to bring us out of a captivity so
melancholy and wretched the delight we
felt let each one conjecture when he
shall remember the length of time we
were in that country the suffering and
perils we underwent we traveled 25
leagues little more or less and reached
a town of friendly indians the alcalde
left us there and went on three leagues
further to a town called kuliakan where
was melchior diaz principal alcalde and
the captain of the province the alcalde
mayor knew of the expedition and hearing
of our return he immediately left that
night and came to where we were
he wept with us giving praise to god our
lord for having extended over us such
great care
he comforted and entertained us
hospitably we left for mexico
many came out on the roads to gaze at us
giving thanks to god for having saved us
from so many calamities
we arrived at mexico on sunday the day
before the vespers of santiago where we
were handsomely treated by the viceroy
and the marquis de valle and welcomed
with joy they gave us clothing and
offered whatever they had
on the day of santiago was a celebration
and a joust of reeds with bulls
you